[MUSIC PLAYING]
SARA ROBINSON: Hello, everyone.
Welcome to Machine
Learning APIs By Example.
Did everyone enjoy the
concert last night?
[CHEERING]
Awesome.
LCD Soundsystem is a
tough act to follow,
but I'm going to try my best.
I'm going to show
you how to access
pre-trained machine learning
models with a single API call.
My name is Sara Robinson.
I'm a Developer Advocate on
the Google Cloud Platform team.
You can find me on
Twitter @SRobTweets.
So to get started at
a high level, what
is machine learning?
Machine learning is
teaching computers
to recognize patterns in the
same way that our brains do.
So it's very easy for a child to
differentiate between a picture
of a cat and a dog.
But it's much, much more
difficult to teach a computer
to do the same thing.
So the idea is, we
train these models
and they improve over time
with more and more data
and experience.
So what we have
here is a diagram
of a typical deep
neural network.
And we can think of the input
to this network as pixels,
and the output is going
to be a prediction.
And the layers
throughout the network
are looking for certain
features in the image.
They're looking for maybe the
shape of the ears, the eyes,
or the nose.
And the output is a
prediction or a classification
as either a cat or a dog.
But let's take a step
back for a moment.
And let's do this
without a neural network.
Let's do some human-powered
image detection.
So looking at these two pictures
of an apple and an orange,
if we were to
write an algorithm,
what are some
features we might look
for in our code to be
able to differentiate
between these two?
You can shout it out
AUDIENCE: Color.
SARA ROBINSON: Color.
Color is a great one.
So if we were to
look for color, we
could look at the majority
of the pixels in the image.
If the majority of the pixels
are red, it's an apple.
If they're orange,
it's an orange.
So that would work great
on these two examples.
Then what if we have
grayscale images?
Then we have to
start all over again
and look for possibly
a different feature.
What might we look
for this time?
AUDIENCE: Texture.
SARA ROBINSON: Texture,
I heard texture.
So we could look at the texture,
that would differentiate
between these two.
But then what would
happen if we got crazy
and added a third fruit,
if we added a mango?
You get the idea.
We'd have to start
all over again.
Now all these pictures
are pretty similar.
These fruits are
all very circular.
So if we instead had
two images of things
that were completely
different, this
should be a pretty
easy task, right?
What if we had a picture
of a dog and a mop,
and we needed to
differentiate between the two.
These two things have
nothing in common, right?
The mop is not
living or breathing,
it doesn't have eyes,
a nose, or a mouth.
It's actually kind of difficult.
[LAUGHTER]
So here we have four pictures
of sheepdogs and mops.
And it's kind of hard
even for the human eye
to tell the difference
between the two.
So the idea here
is we don't want
to write specific
rules in our code
to look for certain
things in our pictures.
We want to write code that will
find these patterns for us.
Because we might not have just
photos of animals and fruit.
We might have photos
of everything.
And in addition to
photos, we might
have other types of
unstructured data
like video, audio, and text.
So what I'm here to talk about
today is a suite of tools
that Google Cloud
Platform offers
to help you make sense
of this unstructured data
through machine learning.
On the left-hand
side, we have tools
to help you build and train your
own machine learning models.
TensorFlow is an open
source framework,
lets you build and
train your own models
with your own custom data.
And Cloud Machine
Learning Engine
lets you run and manage
TensorFlow models on Google's
managed infrastructure.
What I'm going to focus on
today is the right-hand side.
And is what I like to call
friendly machine learning.
These are APIs they give you
access to pre-trained machine
learning models
so that you don't
have to worry about building
and training your own model.
All you need to know how to
do is make a REST API request.
And as developers, you
can focus on building
awesome functionality
into your applications.
So I'm going to give you a tour
of each of these five APIs.
And I'm going to get
started with the Vision API.
So let's dive right in.
The Vision API lets you
perform complex image detection
with a simple REST request.
And before I dive into
the specifics of the API,
for each section,
I want to give you
an example of a
customer that's using it
so that you can
get a sense of how
it's being used in production.
So for the Vision API, my
example is realtor.com,
and they are a real
estate listing service.
And they're using the Vision
API in their mobile app.
So they have an iOS
and Android app.
And when people are out and
about looking at houses,
they can take a
picture on the app.
And they're using the Vision
API's OCR, their Optical
Character Recognition,
to extract the text
from the image of the
listing, and then they
can pull up the relevant
listing inside the application.
Let's take a look at some of
the core features of the Vision
API.
The first one we have here
all the way on the left
is label detection.
And label detection can tell
us, what is this a picture of?
For this picture, it might
tell us cheetah, animal, field,
et cetera.
Then we have face detection.
Face detection can tell us,
are there faces in the image?
If so, where are they,
how many faces are there,
and what emotions can
we find in the image?
Are they happy, sad,
angry, or surprised?
OCR is the use case that I
mentioned on the previous slide
with realtor.com.
So this feature can
identify text in an image.
It can tell you what
language that text is in
and where the text is
located inside the image.
Explicit content detection
is pretty self-explanatory.
This will tell you, is the
image appropriate or not?
This is actually really
useful if you got a site
with a lot of user-generated
content, people uploading
tons and tons of images.
You probably don't
want to have somebody
sitting there manually
classifying each image as
appropriate or not.
Instead, you can just use
an API call to do this,
send the image to
the Vision API,
it'll tell you of the
image is appropriate.
And then you only have
to manually review
a small subset of your images.
Then we have landmark
detection, which can tell us,
is there a common
landmark in this photo?
And what are the
latitude-longitude coordinates
of that landmark?
And finally, logo
detection to tell us,
is there a company logo
present in the image?
So I want to show you what the
JSON response from the Vision
API looks like for just
two of these features.
The first one is face detection.
This is a selfie I took
with two teammates on a trip
to Petra in Jordan last year.
And it returns an object for
each face found in the image.
So this is just the
response for my face.
So we can see that
from my face, it
returns headwear likelihood,
very unlikely, which is true.
I'm not wearing a
hat in the image,
although my two teammates are.
And then joy likelihood
is very likely.
I'm smiling in the image.
It also gives me a lot more data
on where different features are
in my face.
So I can use that
if I want to draw
a box around the face in the
image or something like that.
The next JSON response I want to
show you is landmark detection.
So everyone knows
what this is, right?
This is the Eiffel
Tower in Paris.
It's actually not.
I was fooled too, don't worry.
It is via Paris Hotel
and Casino in Las Vegas.
So I wanted to see, could the
Vision API spot the difference?
And the answer was yes.
With 80% confidence, it's able
to identify this as the Paris
Hotel and Casino in Las Vegas.
And we get the
latitude-longitude
coordinates of that landmark.
So in addition to
those six features
that I just touched on,
a couple of weeks ago,
we added some new features to
the Vision API, which I want
to highlight on this slide.
The first of these
is crop hints.
This will give you
suggested crop dimensions
for your photos.
The second, which I'm
most excited about,
is web annotations, which
lets you search the internet
for more details on your image.
And I'm going to dive
into that in a little bit
more detail on the next slide.
And then finally, we have
document text annotations,
which improves the OCR model.
So if you have images
with lots of text,
like a picture of a receipt or
a business card, or a resume,
the model will do a much
better job extracting all
of that text from the image.
So looking a little more
closely into web annotations,
I'm a big "Harry Potter" fan.
So I'm going to use this image
to show you web annotations.
This is a picture of a car.
It's not just any car.
It's a car from the
"Harry Potter" movies,
and it is currently on
display in a museum.
So I wanted to send this to
the web annotations endpoint
and see what entities it was
able to find in the image.
The first one I found is
Ford Anglia, which is indeed
the correct model of this car.
And then it also returned
Art Science Museum,
which is a museum in Singapore
where the car is currently
on display.
And then finally, it tells us
that this picture is indeed
from "Harry Potter."
We get this all just by
sending the image to the API.
We also get some other things
from the web annotations
endpoint, one of which
is full matching images.
So this will tell us all of
URLs across the web, where
this exact same image exists.
So this is useful if you want
to do any sort of copyright
detection.
If you've got users uploading
an image and you want to say,
OK, has this image already
been published on another site,
you can use full matching
images to get all those URLs.
Partial matching images
is kind of like a search
by image feature.
It'll show you all the visually
similar images on the internet.
And then pages with
matching images
will give you the URL where
all these images were found.
So I encourage you all
to try it in the browser
with your own images.
If you go to
cloud.google.com/vision,
I'll have the link on
the last slide again.
Before you start
writing any code,
you can upload your images
directly in the browser
and see all of
the JSON responses
that I just described
for your image.
Now, I wanted to show you
a demo of the Vision API.
And because we're
at Google I/O, I
wanted to incorporate
Firebase into my demo.
So what I've got here
is a web app that's
hosted on Firebase Hosting.
And it lets users upload images.
The images are stored in
Cloud Storage for Firebase.
And then I'm using the Firebase
SDK for Cloud Functions.
So I've got a function listening
on this storage bucket.
Whenever a new image
is added to the bucket,
it's going to send that
image to the Vision API.
This is an entirely
serverless application.
And the Vision API
returns JSON, which
makes it really easy for us
to just write that response
to a Firebase database.
And then we can display
the result in a web UI.
So if we could
switch to the demo.
Awesome.
So this is the web
app I've got here.
I've got my latest photo.
In this case, it's a coffee cup.
And then I've got
some entities that
are returned from the Vision
API, the total number of photos
I've seen, and then the
total number of emotions
detected if there was
a face in the image.
So I'm going to go ahead
and add a photo here.
I'm going to add this photo
of the Golden Gate Bridge.
And then while
it's uploading, I'm
going to show you my
Firebase database here.
So we can see it was just
uploaded to Cloud Storage.
And my function is being called
right now, there it goes.
My function just wrote the
Vision API response back
to my Firebase database.
And if we look in
here, we can examine
all the different things that
come back from the Vision API,
including pages of
matching images.
We can see the Wikipedia
page where this was found,
which is actually
where I got the image.
And then we can see
some of the web entities
that were returned.
And if we go back
to our app, we can
see that the new picture is
reflected in our application,
that the numbers
of entities were
reflected to represent
the entities that
were found in the image.
So if we could go
back to the slides.
So I just wanted to incorporate
Firebase in this demo
to show you how you can combine
the cloud machine learning APIs
with Firebase to create awesome
web or mobile applications.
I definitely encourage you to
check out these Firebase APIs
that I used.
And going back to our
sheepdog versus mop example,
in case you were wondering,
how did the Vision API perform
on these images?
So if we look at the
response for that dog photo
all the way on the
right, we can see
that the Vision API
was 99% confident
that this was a photo of a dog.
And it's even 77%
confident that it's
a Commodore, which is the
exact breed of dog that is.
Skipping ahead to
our mop photos,
it was 70% confident that
this was a broom or a tool.
And I'm going to skip
ahead and show you
the response for all of them.
So overall, this
pre-trained model
did pretty well on
these images that
are even pretty hard for
the human eye to discern.
So on the dog photos, it
got three out of four.
The third one there, it
didn't return the label dog,
it said fur.
So wasn't sure if that
one was a hit or a miss.
And then on the third
row on the bottom,
it didn't return the label mop
or broom for the third one,
it returned textile.
But overall, this
model was pre-trained.
It wasn't trained specifically
to identify the difference
between dog and mop photos.
But it did a very
good job doing so.
And for each API,
I want to show you
how easy it is to call the API.
I'm going to show you
these examples in Node.
But we have Google
Cloud client libraries.
You can choose the library
in your favorite language
to call the API.
I'm going to use Node because
that's my language of choice.
So here I'm requiring the
Google Cloud Node Module.
And then on my Vision object
I'm just calling a Detect.
I'm passing it in my image file.
And then it returns
the annotations.
I tell it what types of feature
detection I want to run.
I can also pass it, the URL, to
a file stored in Google Cloud
Storage.
So we talked about images.
The next thing I want
to talk about is speech.
So how many of you
have used the OK Google
functionality on your phone?
Looks like most of you.
So what the Speech API does is
it lets developers integrate
that functionality into
their own applications,
lets you do speech to text
transcription in over 80
languages.
An app that's using it
is Azar, and they're
a chat application that has
connected over 15 billion
matches.
And they're using the
Speech API anytime
somebody sends an audio snippet
to someone else in a chat.
And there's a lot of
potential use cases
where you may want to
combine different cloud
machine learning APIs.
In this case, they're using
the Speech API in combination
with the translation API.
So whenever the two people
don't speak the same language,
they'll transcribe the
audio with the Speech API.
And then they'll translate it
into the other person's host
language with the
translation API.
So the best way to see
how the Speech API works
is through a demo.
And first I want to explain what
we're going to do in the demo.
So we're going to
make a recording using
SoX, which is a command
line utility for audio.
And then we're going to create
our API request in a JSON file,
and send the JSON request
to the Speech API.
And then we will receive
the JSON response.
So if we could switch
over to the demo.
Looks like we got that here.
So I'm going to
call my Bash script.
And it's going to
ask me to record
a five-second audio file.
So I'm going to record
something right now.
I built a demo of the Speech
API using SoX at Google I/O.
So I'm going to send
that to the Speech API,
and we can see here what
my JSON request looks like.
We tell it our encoding type.
We can see that it
did pretty well.
It didn't get the
word built, maybe
it's the sound system in here.
I don't the demo of the Speech
API using socks at Google I/O.
But it did get
Google I/O correct.
But notice that it incorrectly
transcribed the word SoX, which
makes sense because SoX
is a proper noun, that's
the command line tool I used
to transcribe the audio.
And that's where
the speech context
parameter comes into play.
So if you have any
sort of proper nouns
that are specific
to your application
that the API might not
otherwise recognize,
like I wouldn't
normally expected
to recognize the
proper noun SoX,
you can pass it these
phrases as hints.
So if I hop on over
here to Sublime,
I'm actually going to add SoX
to that phrases suggestion.
And I'm going to run
the same thing again.
I'm going to make
the same recording.
I built a demo of the Speech
API using SoX at Google I/O.
And we can see it's now looking
for that word in my text,
and I'm going to send
it to the Speech API.
It did pretty well.
Again, might be
the sound in here.
But it did get the
proper noun, thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
You never know with live demos.
So again, just to reiterate,
I added this speech context
parameter so that it was
able to identify correctly
this proper noun that I
wanted to say in my text.
So if we could go
back to the slides.
If we go back to the slides.
Awesome.
So in this demo, I used
a complete audio file.
So I used it in batch mode.
But it also works
in streaming mode.
So if you want to send it a
continuous stream of audio,
you can send it
stream of audio and it
will return transcriptions
as that audio is coming in.
So that's the Speech API.
Once you're done
transcribing your text,
you may want to do more
analysis on your text.
One more thing I
want to talk about
is how you can call the
Speech API from Node.
And so here I've required
the Google Cloud module.
And I just need to tell it the
encoding type, in this case
linear 16, and then the
sample rate in hertz.
And then I call
speech.recognize,
passing it my local file.
Again I can also pass it a file
stored in Google Cloud Storage.
So as I mentioned
before, you might
want to do something
more with your text
once you've transcribed it.
You might want to analyze it.
And that's where the Natural
Language API comes into play.
The Natural Language
API lets you
extracts entities, sentiment,
and syntax from your text.
A customer that's using the API
is a company called Wootric,
and they are a customer
feedback platform.
And what they enable
all of their users to do
is gather feedback
from their app's users
as they're going throughout
their application.
So you may have seen
something like that box
in the top right when you're
on a website or an app.
It asks you, how did you
feel about this experience
on a scale of 0 to 10?
So it's pretty easy for them
to parse those numbered scores.
But Wootric's job is to
help their customers make
sense of all this
open-ended feedback.
And it's that
open-ended text feedback
that's much more difficult
for them to make sense of.
And that's where the Natural
Language API comes into play.
And they're actually
using all the methods
of that Natural Language API.
So they're using sentiment
analysis to say OK,
did the numbered score that
the person gave line up
with the open-ended
feedback that they sent?
And then they're also using
entity and syntax annotation
to pull out the key subjects
and terms from the feedback,
and then if
necessary, route those
to the right person
in near real time
to respond to the feedback.
So let's say there
is a customer who
wrote in and was really
angry about usability
in this application.
They could route that
to the right person
to make sure they got
a response right away,
rather than having
to manually review
each piece of open-ended text.
So I want to dive into each
method of the Natural Language
API, starting with
entity analysis.
So I've got this
sentence and I sent it
to the entity extraction
endpoint of the Natural
Language API.
And it returned all of these
as entities in my text.
And I wanted to show you
the JSON response for some
of these entities, so we can
see that for each entity,
we get the name of the entity--
in this case, Google.
The type of the
entity, organization.
And then we get
back some metadata.
So you'll notice this MID.
This is an ID that maps to
Google's Knowledge Graph.
And if you want to get more
information about the entity,
you can call Google's Knowledge
Graph API, passing it this ID.
And we also get the Wikipedia
URL for this particular entity.
We can see it correctly
identifies I/O as an event.
And then we can see the response
for some of the other entities
here.
And what you'll notice
is that my name is here,
is still returned as an
entity even though I don't
have a Wikipedia page yet.
So if you have
entities in your text
that might not have
associated metadata,
the API will still be able
to extract those as key terms
and give you a response.
It'll just have an
empty metadata object.
So that is entity analysis.
The next thing that
the API lets you do
is analyze the
sentiment of your text.
So if we have this
restaurant review,
the food at that
restaurant had no taste,
I will not be going back.
If I worked at this
restaurant, I'd
probably want to
flag this review
and potentially follow
up with this customer
to see why they didn't like it.
But it's likely that I would
have lots and lots of reviews,
and I probably wouldn't want
to read each one manually.
I might want to flag the most
positive and most negative
ones, and then
respond just to those.
So we get two numbers back
from the Natural Language API
to help us do this.
The first thing we get back
is score, which will tell us
on a scale from negative 1 to
1, how positive or negative
is this text?
In this example, we
get negative 0.8,
which is almost fully negative.
And then we get
magnitude, which tells us
regardless of being
positive or negative,
how strong is the
sentiment in this text?
And this is a range
from 0 to infinity,
and it's normalized based
on the length of the text.
So we get a pretty
small number here, 0.8,
because this is just
a small piece of text.
So that's sentiment analysis.
And the final thing we can do
with the Natural Language API
is analyze syntax.
And this is going to give us
a lot more linguistic details
about the piece of text.
So here we have the sentence,
the Natural Language API
helps us understand text.
And what I'm going to show you
here is a visualization of all
the JSON we get back.
So the first thing we
get back is what we
call a dependency parse tree.
And this tells us which
words in a sentence
depend on each other, what
word depends on this word.
Then we get the parse
label, which will tell us,
what is the role of each
word in the sentence?
So helps is the root
verb in this case.
API and us are nominal subjects.
And then we get the part of
speech which will tell us,
is this a noun, a
verb, or an adjective?
Then we get the lemma.
The lemma is the canonical
form of the word.
So in this case, we
only get one for helps.
The canonical form
of helps is help.
This is useful if
you're counting maybe
how many times a specific
word or term is being
used to describe your product.
You probably don't
want to count helps
and help as two
different things.
You probably want to use
the lemma form to get
the canonical form of the word.
And then finally, we get some
additional morphology details
on the text.
So is it first, second,
or third person?
Is it plural or singular?
And these are
going to vary based
on the language of the text that
you send the Natural Language
API.
So I want to show you a demo
of the Natural Language API.
And how this demo works is I
am using the Twitter Streaming
API to stream tweets
related to Google I/O using
a couple of the search
terms that you see here--
Google I/O, Firebase
Cloud, TensorFlow
and machine learning.
I'm sending the
text of these tweets
to the Natural Language API.
And I'm using the sentiment
and syntax annotation methods.
I'm writing that JSON response
to the Firebase database.
And I'm using the
Firebase database
to only store the most
recent tweets so that I can
display a dashboard of them.
And then I'm writing
all of my tweets
to BigQuery, which is Google
Cloud's big data as a service
tool, lets you easily query
lots and lots of data.
So I've got two separate
processes running for that.
So if we could
switch to the demo.
I'm going to go ahead and
start up my Node server.
And I'm going to go over here.
And what we see here is we have
the latest tweets displaying.
We should see some
start streaming soon.
I'm not displaying the
full text of the tweets
because this is a
public event, so what
could go wrong with displaying
tweets on a giant screen?
And we've got the nouns, verbs,
and adjectives in each tweet.
There we go, we
got some new ones.
And it's displaying the
sentiment of the latest tweets.
So it goes from negative 1 to
1, how positive or negative
is this tweet?
And then we can see--
make this a little bit bigger.
We can see the
sentiment by hashtag.
And we can also see the
most common adjectives
that are being used
in the latest tweets.
So that's pretty cool.
But the other thing I did was
I am sending all of my tweets
to BigQuery for some
historical analysis.
So if I open up the
BigQuery web UI here,
we use SQL to write
queries in BigQuery.
We can see all of
the tweets that I've
collected since I
started streaming this,
which is a couple of days ago.
So I've collected, in
total, over 54,000 tweets.
And this is what my data
looks like in BigQuery.
I can visualize it and
write queries directly
in the browser.
So this is what each row
in my table looks like.
I've got the ID of
the tweet, the text
of the tweet, the timestamp
of when it was created,
the number of
followers the user has,
the hashtags, which is
returned from the Twitter API,
and then I have this
giant JSON string
of all the syntax annotation
data that was returned
from the Natural Language API.
You might be wondering, how am
I going to parse that using SQL?
Well, BigQuery has a feature
called user-defined functions,
which lets you write custom
JavaScript functions that can
be run on rows in your table.
So I've written a function here.
I want to count all
the adjectives that
have been used in all these
tweets that I've streamed.
So this is going to be run over
that syntax annotation JSON
string.
It's going to parse
that JSON string
and count all the adjectives
in all of my tweets so far.
So I'm going to go
ahead and run this.
Keep in mind it's running
this custom function on all
54,000-plus rows in my table.
And we can see it finished
in just under eight seconds.
And if we look down here, we can
see the most common adjectives
that are being used to
describe Google I/O and machine
learning.
And one other thing I wanted
to show you-- thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
One other thing I
wanted to show you
is, this is the Natural
Language API Products Page.
And you can all go here--
I'll share the link at the end--
and try out the Natural
Language API on your own text.
And I wanted to
show you a feature
that we added to the
API just two weeks ago.
And this is
entity-based sentiment.
So within a sentence,
this will give you
the sentiment of specific
entities in your text.
So if I have a sentence like,
I really liked the sushi,
but the service was terrible,
I'm going to send this to API.
And we can see that
sushi got a score of 0.8.
Service got a score
of negative 0.9.
And that's really
useful, because if I
had sent this
sentence to the API
and got a sentiment
analysis response
for the whole
sentence, it probably
wouldn't be too useful to me.
What I really wanted
to know is what
this person liked about specific
entities in my sentence.
So we can go back to the sides.
So with this demo, I
just wanted to show you
how you can combine
Firebase, again,
with Google Cloud Platform,
using Firebase to create
a real time dashboard
of my latest tweet data,
and then BigQuery so that I
can do a historical analysis
once I'm done gathering the data
on all the data I have received
so far.
Another thing that you might
want to do with your text-- oh,
just forgot, the
code snippet here.
So if you want to call
the Natural Language
API from Node.js,
here's a snippet
of code of how
you would do that.
In this example, I am passing
it a file from Google Cloud
Storage.
You can also pass it raw text.
And just call language.annotate,
and it'll give you
your annotation response back.
So the next thing you might
want to do with your text,
once you're done
analyzing it, is
you might want to translate it
into many different languages.
You likely have users for your
application all over the world.
You want to make sure your
app is accessible to them,
wherever they are.
With the Translation API,
you can translate your text
in over 100 languages.
Before I get into
that, I wanted to talk
a bit about Google Translate.
How many of you have used
Google Translate before?
Looks like almost
all hands went up.
I rely on it a
bunch when I travel.
Last year I was on
a trip to Japan,
and I was at a restaurant where
almost nobody spoke English.
And I really wanted
to order octopus.
So I got out my handy
dandy Google Translate
app, typed in the
word for octopus,
and found out that it was taco.
So I was a little confused,
but I decided to roll with it,
order my taco, and I was
able to get this delicious
octopus as a result.
So Google Translate
is very handy for more things
than just translating the word
octopus.
And with the
Translation API, you
can integrate the functionality
of Google Translate
into your own applications.
And one company that's
doing that is Airbnb.
What you might not
know about Airbnb
is that 60% of
their bookings are
between people that
use the application
in different languages.
They're using the
Translation API
not only to translate
the listings,
but also to translate the
reviews and conversations.
And they've found that
using the Translation API
has significantly improved a
guest's likelihood to book.
Here's a snippet of code of how
you would call the Translation
API for Node.js.
And notice here that
I'm only passing
the string I want to translate
along with the language
that I want to translate it to.
I actually don't need
to tell it the source
language of the text.
So another thing you can
do with the Translation
API is if you just want to
detect the language of the text
that a user's typing in, you
can use API for that as well.
So I pass it my text
and the language
I want to translate it to, and
I get the translation back.
Recently, we made
some improvements
to the underlying model
behind the Translation API.
And this new version is called
neural machine translation.
You'll just notice a
difference in the quality
of the translations
as you send your text
through the Translation API.
So the first model of
translation that we use,
called first
generation translation,
the way that works is
it translated each word
in the sentence word for word.
So this might be similar to how
you would translate something
if you were traveling,
had a dictionary with you,
and you wanted to
look up a sentence.
You might translate each
word, word for word.
And the result would
probably be pretty accurate,
but you might miss some
of the linguistic nuances
of that text.
And what neural machine
translation does
is it takes each word and
looks at it in the context
of other words in a sentence.
And it's able to produce a
much more accurate translation.
There's a great "New York
Times" article about it.
I've got a bit.ly
link right there
if you're interested in learning
more about how neural machine
translation works
under the hood.
And just to show you what
the improvements look
like, I know there's a
lot of text on this slide,
I'll explain it.
As I mentioned, I'm a
big "Harry Potter" fan.
And so what we have
all the way on the left
is a paragraph from the
original Spanish version
of "Harry Potter."
And obviously, "Harry Potter"
was not translated via an API.
It's been translated
in over 70 languages.
And they actually
had somebody that
spoke each language in charge of
writing the translated version.
So this is from the
original translated version.
And then in the
middle column, we
see what first generation
translation produced
when I translate it to English.
On the right-hand side, we see
what neural machine translation
produced.
And I just bolded some
of the differences.
So we can see that the verb made
was changed to manufactured,
which is much more specific to
the context of the sentence.
And we can see if we
skip to the bottom, fence
of the gardens changed
to garden fence.
So lots of improvements with
neural machine translation.
The final API I want
to talk about today
is the Video Intelligence API.
And this is the newest addition
to our suite of Cloud Machine
Learning APIs.
What the API lets
you do is understand
your video's entities at
shot, frame, and video level.
A company that's
using this is Cantemo.
They are a media asset
management company.
And all of their customers have
lots and lots of video content.
So they upload their content
to Cantemo's platform.
Cantemo helps them
transcode it, edit it.
And what they're doing
with the Video API
is they're enabling
their customers
to make their video
content searchable so they
can search within their videos.
The best way to see the
Video API is through a demo.
So if we could switch
back to the demo.
What I've got here is
a Superbowl commercial
for Google Home from
this past Superbowl.
And I'm going to play just
the first few seconds of this.
So what we can see here is a
lot of scene changes happening
in this video.
I'm going to stop
it here, but we
can see that it started with
a mountain pass, switched
to a house, then a street scene,
then we saw a dog and a garage.
So if we were to manually
transcribe this video,
we'd have to watch what was
happening in every scene
and write down those
tags and store them
in a database somewhere.
What we get with the
Video Intelligence
API is we get some
data at a high level,
what is this video about?
And then at a more
granular level, what
is happening in every scene?
So if we look down here,
we can see a visualization
of the JSON response we get
back from the Video Intelligence
API.
So it tells us that
there's a dog here.
And not only does it know
that there's a dog this video,
it tells us exactly which
scene the dog appears.
If we skip to the end, we
can see a birthday cake.
And then if we
scroll down, we can
see a couple of other
labels that were returned.
So not only did it
know it was a dog,
it knows exactly what
type of dog it is.
And if we scroll
down a little more,
we notice that it
identifies that mountain
pass from the opening scene.
So this is what the API
can do with one video.
But if you're
analyzing videos, it's
likely that you have lots
and lots of video content.
So you could be a
media company that
has hundreds of
petabytes of videos
sitting in storage buckets.
And one common thing
you might want to do
is create a highlight reel.
You might want to look
for a specific entity
and pull that out across
your entire video library.
And with the JSON
data we get back
from the Video
Intelligence API, it
makes this really easy to do.
So if I go here, I've got quite
a few videos in my library.
And let's say I'm a
sports media company.
So I have lots and
lots of sports footage.
I only want to find the
scenes relevant to baseball.
Oops, go back here.
I'm going to search
for baseball.
And we can see
that, boom, the API
tells us immediately which
videos have baseball in them.
And not only does it tell us
which videos have baseball,
it tells us exactly where in
those videos baseball appears.
So we can see in
this video there's
lots of baseball scenes.
But this one is my
favorite example,
because there's only one, tiny,
one-second clip of baseball
in this video.
This is the year-end
search video
that Google publishes at
the end of every year,
highlighting top searches
from throughout the year.
So if we were to look
through this manually,
we'd have to watch the entire
video just for this one scene.
With the Video API, we can
skip directly to that scene.
And that's from last year's
World Series when the Cubs won.
And we might have even missed
that scene if we were manually
reviewing the video.
So I'm going to do
one more search.
Since we're at Google I/O, I'm
going to search for Android.
I'm going to find all the
Android phones in my videos.
And we can see that
I'm jumping here
and I can see exactly
all the places
where Android phones appear in
my video, which is pretty cool.
So with the Video Intelligence
API, what used to take
hours now takes minutes.
And it's easy to search a
large library of video content.
If we could go
back to the slides?
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
I wanted to share
a little bit of how
that demo works under the hood.
All of the video content
is stored in a Google Cloud
Storage bucket.
And I've got a cloud function
listening on that bucket.
So whenever a new
video is added,
that cloud function is going
to send the video to the Video
Intelligence API.
And one of the
request parameters
that I get with the Video API
is it lets me pass it a file
URL of a Google Cloud
Storage file where I
want to write my JSON response.
So when it's done
annotating the video,
I write that response to a
separate Google Cloud Storage
bucket.
And the front end
of this application
is a Node.js app running
on Google App Engine.
So the front end of the
app doesn't actually
call the Video API directly.
It simply references the videos
from one Cloud Storage bucket
and then gets the associated
metadata from another Cloud
Storage bucket.
Here's what the JSON response
looks like for label detection.
So we can see in
this video, there's
a scene with a bird's eye view.
It tells us what the
label is, bird's eye view.
We get the start and end time
of this label in microseconds.
And if this label appeared
in more than one scene,
there'd be multiple
segment objects there.
And we also get a
confident score.
It's 96% confident that it's
identified this correctly.
Here's another one from the
same video of a portrait label.
We also get the start and
end time for this label.
And here's some code
of how you would
call the Video API for Node.js.
The Video API's currently
in private beta.
So that's all I've got today.
That concludes my presentation.
I really encourage you all
to start using the ML APIs,
and you can try them all
directly in the browser.
So if you go to
the browser, I only
showed you the Natural Language
API demo in the browser.
But all of the APIs
have a browser demo
where you can add your
own data before you start
writing any code and see all
of the API responses visualized
directly right there.
I've got the code for some of
the demos you saw in this talk
in my personal GitHub.
ML Talk Demos has the code
for most of the demos.
I haven't yet added
the Firebase ones,
but I hope to do that soon.
And then the Video
API demo app code
is in a separate repo
on my personal GitHub
under Video Intelligence Demo.
So I encourage you all to
try them out and get started.
And thank you for coming.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]